demis toi qui tu as prête à faire une
tournée des cathédrales tout n'est pas
surpris de te retrouver dans un
confessionnal
ah non pas du tout moi j'ai visite
souvent le monastère chinois en grèce
et j'ai des discussions longues avec les
moines sur beaucoup de choses de la vie
donc ça prouve que je suis un croyant
jeu pas très pratiquants d'ailleurs mais
les cathédrales les ou quelque chose de
mystique de magique et c'est un vieux
rêve que j'avais et c'est pour ça je
vais faire presque toute la france en
chantant des chants de noël des chants
religieux et puis quelques chansons de
mon répertoire qui s'apprête bien dans
cellule on n'a vu qu'une expérience
mystique de 15 à 19 ans est ce que tu es
aussi attirés par le paranormal
tu as dit si je voulais je pourrais être
médium
pourquoi tu veux pas parce que les
touches des médiums ya pas certains gens
qui sont plus que les autres et certains
gens qui jugent qu'ils ont et qu'ils ont
été exercés plus que les autres ce dont
tu crois en la réincarnation en 1976 tu
disais être la réincarnation d'alexandre
le grand
c'est vérifié commence battue c'est nous
les grecs on est tous un peu
alexandre des connards tous un type et
alexandre le grand est du genre bah
damour
comme chaque espagnol et le type est
donc qui cote en 1987 cette fois tu
étais convaincu être un ancien far as tu
choisi pas mal et j'ai vécu un ancien
l'egypte et je vécus au moyen âge et
je pense que je veux qu avec alexandre
avec alexandre des grands macédonie et
mais je me cherche toujours
parfois tu dis aussi être un soldat dans
l'es7 d'angleterre et être moore d'un
coup de lance dans la gorge et tu dis
que pendant le temps où tu as été pris
en otage par les terreaux ici j'adore ce
ressenti une violente douleur dans la
gorge
oui ça c'est vrai ta grand mère c'est
vrai que tu la vois des fois derrière
toi et elle est toujours là et moi même
ma grand mère paternelle et je la vois
aussi tu l'as vu ce soit ce soir non pas
ici il ya trop de lait trop de
vibrations trop de trop d'énergie trop
de s'il y avait quand même la peau spurs
électrique ce soir et je sais pas si
c'est dans toutes les émissions mais
dans celle là je suis sûr qu'ils en
avaient donc les bonne s p vient pas et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou